[Music]
Riverdale star Madeleine peche stepped
out for the 2017 GQ Men of the Year
event in LA Thursday night and the
actress dished on that surprising twist
for her character Cheryl and Ashley
Marie's Chelsea girls I'm so sorry I
didn't know anyone was still in here
your characters very into Josie now what
was your reaction to that storyline I
was like I'm always down for some for
some good Josie laughing I mean Ashley's
beautiful and I think there's not a lot
of representation of bisexual characters
on television so I'm happy to be able to
join the game love it what else can you
tease for us about what's coming up what
you can tell us there is more unexpected
love interests where that came from
Reggie's texting me that his dad is
gonna pay me $5,000 for five songs as
long as he gets to escort me what about
love stories so there has been a little
bit of a touchy development between
Josie and Reggie which people seem to be
taking too which is nice
there was a quick resurgence of Chuck
Clayton and I'm not totally sure that
that's going to be a thing in a few
words how would you describe those
relationships we'll see exciting I love
to see her smile for once she cries
[Music]
you